квантова заплутаність дозволяє частинкам бути пов'язаними незалежно від відстані між ними — це настільки нелогічно,
що навіть Ейнштейн не вірив у це. У сьогоднішньому випуску «Qiskit у класі» ми поговоримо про те, як теорема Белла
довела, що Ейнштейн
помилявся. Ласкаво просимо до «Qiskit у класі». У цій серії ми використаємо Qiskit, щоб дослідити деякі фундаментальні концепції, які зазвичай
розглядаються в курсах з квантових обчислень. До кожного відео також буде додаватись інтерактивний модуль,
посилання на який є в описі нижче — обов'язково подивись. У відео про квантові монети ми обговорювали, як вимірювання
квантової суперпозиції є за своєю природою імовірнісним процесом — чимось на кшталт підкидання монети. Але як ми можемо це знати?
Чи може бути так, що квантова частинка приховано зберігає заздалегідь визначений результат вимірювання, але ми чомусь не можемо
відобразити цю інформацію в нашій теорії? На початку квантової механіки це питання було предметом
гострих дискусій між двома основними таборами. В одному таборі був Ейнштейн, який вважав, що квантова механіка є неповною,
тобто що в ній бракує деяких змінних, необхідних для повного опису системи. Ейнштейн думав, що
ці так звані приховані змінні, якщо їх знайти, дозволять вирішити деякі з очевидно парадоксальних і імовірнісних
аспектів квантової механіки. В іншому таборі був Макс Борн. Борн стверджував,
що імовірнісний опис, який дає квантова механіка, — це все, що задається природою. Іншими словами,
справа не просто в тому, що ми не знаємо стан частинки до її вимірювання, — частинка не має певного стану
до того, як її виміряють. Десятиліттями багато хто вважав цю суперечку філософським питанням, яке може так і не бути
вирішене. Адже щоб дізнатися щось про систему, нам потрібно її виміряти. Як ми взагалі можемо дізнатися
щось про природу стану до його вимірювання? Але в 1964 році фізик
Джон Белл знайшов спосіб. У своїй статті Белл дослідив статистичні кореляції між вимірюваннями пари
заплутаних частинок. Якщо до вимірювання стани частинок визначалися якимись невідомими прихованими
змінними, то Белл виявив, що їхні кореляції мають верхню межу. З іншого боку, коли він розрахував
кореляції, передбачені квантовою механікою, то виявив, що вони порушують цю межу. Отже, він знайшов спосіб раз
і назавжди розрізнити погляди Ейнштейна і Борна. Залишалося лише реально експериментально
перевірити ці кореляції на реальних частинках, щоб дізнатися, чи підпорядковуються вони статистиці прихованих змінних, чи
порушують це правило. Ці тести проводилися з дедалі більшою точністю та вишуканістю
протягом багатьох років і є одними з найзначущіших експериментів сучасної фізики. Вони були настільки новаторськими, що
принесли трьом фізикам Нобелівську премію у 2022 році. Але сьогодні будь-хто може провести
тест Белла. Все, що нам потрібно, — це трохи знань з Qiskit та доступ до квантового комп'ютера IBM. У цьому відео я
проведу тебе через логіку нерівності Белла, а потім покажу, як ми можемо перевірити передбачення Белла на квантовому комп'ютері IBM.
Нерівність Белла включає кілька різних вимірювань і рівнів логіки, і в ній може бути
трохи складно розібратися, але ми пройдемо крок за кроком — і в кінці воно того варте. Ми ось-ось покажемо,
що заплутаність реальна, а Ейнштейн помилявся. Не так багато людей можуть сказати, що зробили це. Отже, ось що
запропонував Белл. Припустимо, у тебе є спосіб отримати багато копій заплутаної пари частинок. Фізично
такі пари можуть утворюватися в процесі розпаду, де одна частинка розпадається на дві. Якщо ти дивився відео про
експеримент Штерна–Герлаха, то знаєш, що частинки можуть мати власний кутовий імпульс —
спін. Припустімо, що одна частинка з нульовим спіном розпадається на дві частинки зі спіном 1/2.
Тоді кожну з двох частинок зі спіном 1/2 можна виміряти так, що вона матиме або спін +1/2, або −1/2,
або ж — спін «вгору» чи «вниз». Але оскільки вони виникли з частинки з нульовим спіном, ці дві частинки разом повинні мати
сумарний спін рівний нулю. Тому якщо одна вимірюється як «вгору», то інша мусить бути
«вниз», і навпаки. Ці частинки утворюють заплутану пару, яка виглядає ось так.
Отже, якщо одна вимірюється як «вгору», то інша — «вниз», і навпаки. Припустімо, що частинка 1 відлітає вліво,
тобто в напрямку −X, де дослідник на ім'я Lucas вимірює її
спін. Тоді частинка 2 так само відлітає вправо,
де інший дослідник — Rihanna — може виміряти цей спін. Lucas і Rihanna можуть незалежно
повертати свої вимірювальні пристрої, щоб обирати, вздовж якого напрямку вимірювати спін своїх відповідних частинок,
перпендикулярного до напрямку руху частинки. Якщо ми надішлемо багато копій заплутаного стану до Lucas
і Rihanna, вони можуть збирати вимірювальну статистику. Якщо вони завжди вимірюють вздовж однієї й тієї ж осі, ця статистика не буде
дуже цікавою: щоразу, коли один вимірює спін «вгору», інший вимірює спін «вниз», і щоразу, коли один вимірює спін
«вперед», інший вимірює спін «назад», тощо. Але якщо двоє дослідників вимірюють вздовж різних осей, ми можемо виявити
щось цікавіше. Дамо Lucas і Rihanna три осі для
вимірювання. Назвемо ці осі a, b та c, і вони розділені
на 120° одна від одної. Питання, яке ми поставимо в цьому експерименті: якщо Lucas і Rihanna вільно можуть вимірювати вздовж будь-якої з трьох
осей, як часто вони обоє отримуватимуть однаковий знак? Очевидно, якщо Lucas і Rihanna вимірюють вздовж однієї й тієї ж осі,
наприклад осі a, вони ніколи не отримають однаковий знак, оскільки частинки разом повинні мати нульовий спін. Але коли вони обирають
різні осі, як їхні вимірювання будуть корелювати — якщо взагалі? Згідно з Ейнштейном, цей квантово-
механічний опис стану частинки є неповним. Він вважав, що мають існувати приховані змінні, які
заздалегідь визначають результат усіх можливих вимірювань спіну — адже без цього заплутані частинки мусили б якимось чином
миттєво передавати одна одній результат свого вимірювання. Якби одна була виміряна як «вгору» десь там,
то інша мусила б миттєво «знати», що вона — «вниз» ось тут.
Ці приховані змінні можуть бути будь-яким складним набором інструкцій щодо результату експериментів, але суть у тому,
що спіновий стан кожної частинки окремо є визначеним — тому ніякої передачі інформації не потрібно.
WEBVTT
Експериментально це означало б, що вимірювання Lucas ніяк не впливають на частинку Rihanna, і навпаки.
Це могло б накладати певні обмеження на те, наскільки сильно корелюють два вимірювання. Але за Борном цей стан —
все, що можна сказати про пару частинок до вимірювання. Тому вимірювання однієї частинки
впливає на результат вимірювання іншої. Це може мати різні наслідки для кореляцій між вимірюваннями. Подивімося, як кожна
теорія впливає на ці кореляції. У підході з прихованими змінними є таємний набір інструкцій до
вимірювання, який уже визначає, що Lucas виміряє вздовж кожної з трьох осей. Наприклад, ці
інструкції могли б бути: позитивно, якщо Lucas вимірює вздовж осі a,
позитивно, якщо він вимірює вздовж b, і негативно, якщо вздовж c. Це можна
записати як +a, +b і −c. Тоді частинка Rihanna
мала б мати змінні −a, −b і +c, щоб забезпечити нульовий
сумарний спін вздовж будь-якого одного напрямку.
Є вісім наборів можливих інструкцій, що задовольняють це обмеження нульового спіну. Тому кожного разу, коли нова пара
частинок надсилається до Lucas і Rihanna, вона може містити будь-який із цих восьми наборів інструкцій. Тепер ми хочемо
з'ясувати: припускаючи, що частинки містять один із таємних наборів інструкцій із таблиці, і
припускаючи, що Lucas і Rihanna кожен незалежно обирає, вздовж якої з трьох осей вимірювати, — яка
ймовірність того, що вони обоє виміряють однаковий знак? Якщо інструкції відповідають рядкам 1 або
8, то ця ймовірність явно рівна нулю, оскільки дві частинки матимуть протилежні знаки незалежно від їхніх
осей вимірювання. А як щодо інструкцій у рядку 2? Вони вимірюватимуть однакові знаки, якщо
Rihanna вимірює вздовж c, а Lucas — вздовж a або b; або якщо Lucas
вимірює вздовж c, а Rihanna — вздовж a або b. Тобто чотири з дев'яти
можливих комбінацій вимірювань дадуть Lucas і Rihanna однаковий знак. Якщо зробити це для
кожного набору інструкцій, ти побачиш, що рядки з 3 по 7 також дають ймовірність 4/9. Це означає, що якщо
Ейнштейн правий і такі приховані змінні наперед визначають результат вимірювань, то Lucas
і Rihanna ніяк не можуть виміряти однаковий знак з ймовірністю, більшою за 4/9. Це і є нерівність Белла: P ≤
4/9. І як ми покажемо, заплутані частинки порушують це. Отже, щоб
побачити, що передбачає квантова механіка, припустімо, що Lucas вимірює вздовж a. Можливі два варіанти: або він вимірює спін «вгору» —
тоді Rihanna виміряє спін «вниз» вздовж a — або він вимірює спін «вниз», і Rihanna виміряє спін «вгору» вздовж a. Але нас
цікавить ймовірність того, що Rihanna виміряє той самий знак, що й Lucas, вздовж будь-якої осі за її вибором — не тільки a. Якщо
вона вимірює вздовж b або c, стає трохи складніше. Виявляється, що
якщо ти знаєш, що Rihanna виміряє зі 100% впевненістю вздовж одного напрямку, то можеш розрахувати ймовірності
того, що вона виміряє «вгору» або «вниз» вздовж будь-якої іншої осі, за допомогою трохи геометрії.
Якщо стан завжди вимірюється як спін «вгору» вздовж однієї осі, то ймовірність виміряти спін «вгору» вздовж іншої осі
буде рівна квадрату косинуса половини кута між двома осями. Це трохи складно, але
зараз поясню. Якщо Lucas вимірює спін «вгору» вздовж a, ми зі 100% впевненістю знаємо, що Rihanna виміряє
спін «вниз», якби вона вимірювала вздовж a. Тому можемо зобразити це вектором
ось так. У цьому випадку кути між цим вектором і двома іншими осями вимірювання b і c рівні
60°. Отже, половина від цього — 30°, і косинус
30° показано тут. Косинус у квадраті
30° = 3/4. Тепер що, якщо Lucas вимірює спін «вниз»
вздовж a? Ми знаємо, що Rihanna виміряє спін «вгору» вздовж a — тому тут можна намалювати ще один вектор.
Цей вектор, що відображає це знання, знаходиться під кутом 120° до кожної з двох інших осей b
та c. Тому можемо застосувати той самий геометричний прийом, але цього разу отримаємо косинус
60°. Отже, косинус у квадраті
60° = 1/4. Оскільки Lucas з однаковою ймовірністю
виміряє спін «вгору» і «вниз» вздовж a, нам потрібно усереднити ці дві ймовірності для Rihanna. У підсумку отримаємо
ймовірність того, що Rihanna виміряє той самий знак, що й Lucas, рівну 1/2. Отже, P
= 1/2. Це більше, ніж 4/9, тому нерівність Белла порушується.
Це означає, що якщо правила квантової механіки виконуються, приховані змінні неможливі. Тепер ми можемо використати Qiskit і
квантовий комп'ютер IBM, щоб перевірити нерівність Белла за допомогою реальних квантових вимірювань. Ми можемо зіставити стани спіну «вгору» і
«вниз» частинок Lucas і Rihanna зі станами 0 і 1 qubit'ів у квантовому комп'ютері. Ми беремо
два qubit'и — один для представлення частинки Lucas, інший для Rihanna — і заплутуємо їх за допомогою цього quantum circuit.
Отже, два qubit'и зображені двома дротами q0 і q1, а ця комбінація
gate'ів X, Hadamard та CNOT створить той самий заплутаний стан, що був між частинками Lucas і Rihanna. Тепер нам
потрібно виміряти кожен qubit. Встановимо вимірювання Lucas вздовж a, що ми назвемо віссю Z. Тоді вимірювання Rihanna
може бути вздовж a, b або c — тому нам знадобляться три окремих circuit'и для кожного з цих трьох випадків. Але в цьому
відео ми розглянемо лише один. Для повної версії перейди до модуля з посилання в описі. Якщо Rihanna вимірює вздовж
b, наш circuit виглядає ось так, де RY — це поворот на 120° для зміни
осі вимірювання Rihanna. Ми можемо використати примітив Qiskit Sampler, щоб запустити цей експеримент багато разів і зібрати
статистику з отриманих вимірювань. Два стовпці — 00 і 11 — відповідають моментам, коли Lucas і
Rihanna виміряли однаковий знак, — а це саме те, що нас цікавить. Отже, ймовірність того, що обидві частинки матимуть
однаковий знак, дуже близька до 1/2. Це порушує нерівність Белла. Це означає,
WEBVTT
що дві частинки є заплутаними — кожна з них якимось чином миттєво «знає» результат вимірювання
іншої. Досі тривають дискусії про те, як саме інтерпретувати цю
заплутаність і що відбувається під час вимірювання заплутаного стану. Але ці питання більше філософські —
теорія на цьому етапі практично незаперечна. Заплутаність — це безперечно реальне явище, і ми знаємо це завдяки Беллу, його
нерівності та численним фізикам, які проводили експерименти для її перевірки. Якщо ти хочеш приєднатися до них
і провести власний тест Белла на квантовому комп'ютері, обов'язково перейди до модуля з нерівністю Белла,
посилання на який є в описі. Дякую за перегляд і до зустрічі наступного разу!